[Music]
my name is Ryan fob's Graves and I'm a
former F-18 pilot with a decade of
service in the U.S Navy my name is David
Charles grush I was an intelligence
officer for 14 years in the both in the
U.S Air Force at the Ranka major and
most recently at the National geospatial
Intelligence Agency my name is David
fraver I'm a retired commander in the
United States Navy
now those three men testified before
Congress today revealing shocking
details about what we call UFOs but the
government calls uaps or unidentified
aerial phenomenon now for decades these
men served our country with honor and no
one at that bipartisan hearing today
called into question their integrity or
their credibility
but the testimony it has to be taken
seriously
UAP are in our airspace but they are
grossly underreported these sightings
are not rare or isolated they are
routine military air crew and commercial
pilots trained observers whose lives
depend on accurate identification are
frequently witnessing these phenomena I
was informed
course of my official duties of a
multi-decade UAP crash retrieval and
reverse engineering program the
technology that we faced was far
superior than anything that we had
you're talking something can go into
space go someplace drop down in a matter
of seconds do whatever it wants and
leave
and there's nothing we can do about it
nothing
they even talked about some of the
g-forces that they've seen which in
simplest terms it's when you feel your
body accelerating Against Gravity
about g-forces let's talk about g-forces
of those Vehicles could a human survive
those g-forces with known technology
today no no not for the acceleration
rates that we observed
and some of the claims were quite
literally out of this world if you
believe we have crashed craft as stated
earlier do we have the bodies of the
pilots who piloted this craft biologics
came with some of these recoveries yeah
um
were they I guess human or non-human
biologics
non-human and that was the assessment of
people with direct knowledge on the
program I talked to that are currently
still on the program
now what I think everybody wants to know
at this point is how has all of this
been happening
without the public discovering it and
without the government being frankly
totally transparent on what has gone on
all these years with all the claims of
conspiracy theories now we're learning
it just now
well this exchange does provide a bit of
an answer
do you have knowledge or do you have
reason to believe that there are
programs in the advanced Tech space that
are unsanctioned
uh yes I do how does a program like that
get funded
I will give you generalities I can get
very specific in a closed session uh but
a misappropriation of funds and uh does
that mean does that mean that there is
money in the budget that is said to go
to a program but it doesn't and it goes
to something else yes I have specific
knowledge of that yep
yeah it's all fungible it's your it's
your money taxpayers but they can just
pick it out of any pot they want because
it's all together well don't expect this
lack of transparency to be turned around
anytime soon though certainly not from
this white house uh David Rush who sat
on a U.S Air Force panel on uaps he says
that he was informed of a UAP crash
retrieval and reverse engineering
program based on interviewing 40
Witnesses over four years does such a
program exist and do you believe that
the American people deserve to know if
it does I have no information on that to
provide for you today one way or the
other
one way or another
well as astounding as it is to hear
these revelations in an open
Congressional hearing
the claims of intimidation the claims of
harassment to keep this story hidden
from the American public that may be
actually the biggest bombshell here I do
have knowledge of um
active planned reprisal activity against
myself and other colleagues there were
certain colleagues of mine that were
brutally administratively attacked I
called administrative terrorism that's
their their quiver their tool in the
toolbox to silence people
this suppression campaign may have gone
much further than administrative action
though
do you have any personal knowledge of
people who've been harmed or injured in
efforts to cover up or conceal these
extraterrestrial technology yes
personally
have you heard have anyone been murdered
that you would think that you know of or
have heard of I guess I have to be
careful asking that question I directed
people with that knowledge to the
appropriate authorities
it's not just intimidation action these
accusations they demand immediate
investigation because you know we're
funding this we the people have a right
to know what our government is hiding
from us and these tactics to cover up
and and you know retaliate against
anyone who's speaking out on the issue
this it couldn't be of any greater
importance and we've seen this happen
time and again throughout our government
it's why people don't trust the
government this is not just a National
Security emergency this is an emergency
of trust our trust in the government
itself hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else